an der anrather straße hat die stadt
griff hält einen schönen neuen radweg
gebaut 170000 euro hat das gute stück
gekostet und ist durchaus gelungen wäre
da nicht das merkwürdige ende
hier ist direkt vor einem bahngleis
schluss und dann geh radweg erst drüben
auf der anderen seite weiter
die krefelder sind völlig perplex auf
einmal stand vor denen vor der schiene
und habe gesagt was er von quark weil da
fehlt ein stück katastrophe würde ich
mal sagen also eine planerische
katastrophe weil was macht es für einen
sinn einen radweg zu planen der dann
halt immer wieder unterbrochen ist das
macht ja keinen sinn ob die leute die da
planen noch nie fahrrad gefahren sind
ich weiß es nicht ob die noch nie vor
ort waren die müssen wir das doch wissen
das ist unbegreiflich
der neue 330 meter lange radweg soll die
radfahrer schützen weil hier viel
schwerlastverkehr ins industriegebiet
unterwegs ist aber an der engsten und
gefährlichsten stelle geht es nicht
weiter und die radfahrer müssen umkehren
sie müssen sich hier wieder ins getümmel
stürzen und auf der straße die gleise
überqueren
erst dahinter geht es wieder auf den
sicheren radweg man hat eigentlich immer
das gefühl von hinten es kommt eine
unter rand einer irgendwie an das ist
lebensgefährlich
aber warum baut die stadt einen radweg
ohne den dringend erforderlichen
bahnübergang gleich mit zu bauen
wir hatten 2010 als wir den radweg
geplant haben zwei möglichkeiten jetzt
bauen und fördermittel abschöpfen oder
zwei bis drei jahren noch auf die
genehmigung warten für den bahnübergang
dann wäre die förderung weg gewesen weil
die stadt den radweg zu 90 prozent durch
fördergelder bezahlt bekommt wird erst
mal munter drauflos gebaut ohne zu
wissen ob der bahnübergang überhaupt vom
eisenbahnbundesamt genehmigt wird eine
fehlplanung ist es auf jeden fall nicht
wir haben das gemacht was in unserer
hand lag jetzt warten wir wie gesagt auf
die genehmigungen und das kann als zwei
bis drei jahre dauern
die krefelder können gar nicht glauben
dass das hier noch jahrelang so bleiben
soll
er ist leider eine schande dass
dass das nicht weiter durch gedacht wird
dass steuergelder verpasst werden und
die sicherheit der radfahrer wird dann
wieder stiefmütterlich behandelt und man
muss dann halt wieder warten bis dann
irgendwelche gremien darüber entscheiden
wir wünschen uns schon ewig das heißt ja
mal mal vernünftig läuft aber ich weiß
nicht ob ich das noch in meinem alltag
erleben dass wir das hinkriegen wann die
lücke im radweg endlich geschlossen wird
kann uns niemand sagen solange geht es
für die radfahrer an der anrather straße
in krefeld weiterhin drunter und drüber